so here's a part that no one is talking
about and I said this three weeks ago on
the podcast here's what I said when
Biden went Biden went into our oil
reserve and we saw gas prices dropping
and nobody was bitching about gas prices
and that took place when that happened
that affected votes watch how gas prices
are going to go back up the deal with
Saudi the deal with them stop using our
own Reserve you're going to see gas
prices go back up inflation Wall Street
Journal came out talking about the fact
that if you can pull up this article
Wall Street Journal talking about the
fact that we're going to go to six
percent some investors are afraid that
we're about to go to a two decade high
in the next month that you can see this
article article right here if you zoom
in a little bit some investors bet fed
could lift rates to two decade high now
they're talking about this we haven't
had a point hike we've had three
quarters of a basis point height what if
they do a point hike in a month of
December what if they do they could do
it maybe they're gonna go they're
probably going to do a half or three
quarters of a point but maybe they could
do a point half is locked into talking
about great timing if gas prices all of
a sudden go like this on the next week
to the roof just know it was perfect
timing strategy from Biden for the left
to know that the gas prices being lower
got the average voter to say I'm cool
it's not as high as it used to be
what happened with Dow this last two
weeks three weeks that was at what right
now 34.35 a lot of people knew the
Republicans were about to win the house
so the Republicans winning the house the
the people are like listen I'm cool I'm
not going to be doing anything with it
Dow had a 500 Point day how is Dow doing
right now by the one Kirsten 300 points
it's up 300 points s p up 22. there you
go you know what the market is saying
that was at 33 thou just a month and a
half ago two months ago Dow hit 28
dollar 28.5 and it's at 33 thou when
this thing goes up the way it has it
helps the midterms the economy in the
last four to six weeks helped the
midterms a lot the economy in the last
four to six weeks now when we hear about
what's going on with home value losing a
trillion and a half dollars of equity in
the last five months this hasn't yet hit
in 2023. it's going to be very
interesting what happens to the market
now that there is no gaming the system
or the economy meaning you're about to
really find out what our economy is like
the next three to six months so some of
it in the last three months could have
been fake some of it in the last six
weeks could have been fake there is no
reason to game the economy the next six
months meaning if [ __ ] hits the fan with
the economy the next six months what's
Biden going to say well you know this is
because the house won him this is
because there's so many things to blame
but whatever happens to the economy the
next six months is the real economy no
gamesmanship on both sides it's going to
be very very interesting Tom I want to
go to here with all these things that
we're looking at right now what do you
think is going to happen with the
economy you're seeing the same stats I'm
seeing what do you think is going to
happen to the economy post midterm
elections I think you're exactly right I
think the first thing that's going to
happen is the shoot the other shoe is
going to drop on gas prices because the
manipulation with the Strategic
petroleum Reserve stops because remember
he can only do that once and then they
have to backfill the petroleum Reserve
it's not like some magic Genie fills it
up at night you have to go back and fill
it up again so you can use it again it's
like a savings account of oil for when
the United States States is in trouble
that's I think what people should look
at that spr when you hear that and you
don't have that trick to make the prices
run so I think gas is going up number
one and there hear me now and hear me
clearly there may be gridlock in
Washington they may not be getting
anything done or maybe no change but
I'll tell you where there is still going
to be change and that is at the grocery
store because the prices are continuing
to go up and so there may be grid like
in Washington but there's not going to
be gridlock in their wallets and their
purses on their credit cards because the
price is still going up prices are going
up the market is still reacting to
values of
you know accelerated assets and these
assets went up in value because we
printed money so the average person
needs to look at it and say the stock
market is going up for reasons that are
more related to what we did printing
money and less related to the health of
the economy because when they look at
their wallets they go to the grocery
store they go to get a haircut they go
the thing the prices are going up and I
do not think it's going to be a happy
fourth quarter if you were taking a look
between the lines at the election you
were seeing there were polls out there
that were saying people were actually
going to take Thanksgiving off did
anybody see some of this that they
weren't going to spend as much on the
big meal and they maybe weren't going to
travel to a family member if it required
air travel or some real using gas
traveling five miles is that they might
take Thanksgiving off compared to the
way they would spend in other years
friends that's two weeks from now so I
think we're going to see a shoe drop on
gas prices I think we're already hearing
whispers about her Americans that are
going to modify their Thanksgiving plans
is supposed to be a time at Thanksgiving
getting the family together you know
remember Thanksgiving is a neutral
holiday it's not Hanukkah the first part
of December and Christmas the last half
of December and then Festivus for the
rest of us some other point of December
it's you know it's a good podcast of
this reference Thanksgiving is supposed
to be all of us taking a break and then
spending what we don't have on Black
Friday but you know I have a question
that's what's going on Pat I I think I
think things are are right around the
corner from real and really bad and I
think people are going to sit back and
go well wait a minute now what now what
does the news media talk about now that
this mini-series called the midterm
elections is over Tom question for you
and Pat as well as business guys uh odds
everything's about odds what are the
odds that over the next two years that
the economy
goes up
stays flat or goes down what do you
think the odds are we haven't reached
bottom yet I'd love to know what other
people think and I mean what do you
think do you follow these things now as
closely as you did when you were
Governor where economic statistics could
move your constituents and be a great
concern what are your thoughts no I
think everything you just said is right
I think exactly the manipulation of the
Strategic petroleum Reserve was clearly
for this election cycle and I think that
it was artificial and I think we have a
real energy problem and a shortage and I
think we're going to see gas prices go
up I think the economy will continue to
be a problem I think what you guys are
talking about increase in Flight uh
interest rates all of those things are
going to be sort of like how it was in
the late 70s when Jimmy Carter was the
president and that's why whoever wins
that Republican nomination 2024 I know
we talked about the economy this time
around but if this continues to get is
worse and not better
I think it's going to be a change
election in 2024 and the Republicans
whoever their candidate is I think we'll
have a real good chance to win now if
the economy improves it's a very
different story but I'm betting that
what you just said is likely to happen
I don't think we've seen the bottom yet
before we can talk about what are the
odds of it getting better I don't think
we've seen the bottom first you have to
call the bottom the late Mark Haynes
called the bottom magnificently in 2009
on cnbc's Squawk on the street and he
was the First Financial reporter to do
so and he was dead on he said this is it
this is it this is it I'm calling bottom
and I I don't think we're there yet and
I'm waiting for a voice to do that but I
don't think it's going to be this year
and I don't think it's going to be first
quarter
yeah I think uh again everything is we
will see nobody knows but if gas prices
go up guess what tap it into the
reserves to get the average American
who's not feeling a pain of gas was an
effective strategy by Biden's
Administration especially knowing this
is the lowest level of approval rating
by President since Truman not even
Carter by the way it's lower than Carter
it's at truman levels so if the if the
gas prices goes up you'll see it
interest rates are going to go up
mortgage prices are going to go down
unemployment hasn't even been hit yet we
still have to see those things taking
place I think 2023 is going to be rude
awakening when it comes down to the
economy we still haven't gone through
but again we will support your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]